if you were at the oscars you might
forget you're in america
so many famous actors in hollywood not
only gave stellar performances but
pulled off
impressively realistic accents he has
that northern english accent
he's like jon snow from australia to the
uk
these actors have the skills to fool
audiences into believing they are from
the us
let's have a look and see whose accents
were so convincing
we had no idea they weren't american
you want to come up for some tea or
something the 24 year old actress took
hollywood by storm in 2019
with critically acclaimed performances
in midsomar and little women
while she seemed to appear from nowhere
the fact is
she was busy working in england pew was
born in oxford but has an american
accent so convincing
we wouldn't know it everybody always
says oh you must be really clever and
i'm like nope
she said she'd been working on her
american accent for a long time
the first accent she did was when she
was in school and that is actually what
gave her the idea to pursue acting
she may be only 16 but both her acting
and accent skills are beyond her years
the spanish-born actress that portrays
11 on stranger things
was raised in dorset england from the
time she was a toddler giving her a
naturally british accent
and i called them becca and david
she credits her brilliant american
accent to watching the tv show
hannah montana when she was a kid in the
words of the teen pop star
she's got the best of both worlds bale
has impressed audiences with his slick
and precise roles
from patrick bateman and american psycho
to bruce wayne in the dark knight
trilogy
to dick cheney in vice the long list of
successful american roles
is part of the reason people were so
shocked to learn that bale
is actually welsh look at all of us what
a bunch of lucky buggers we are right
bale's co-star on american psycho
gwenevere turner
said he never spoke in his welsh accent
and he didn't socialize with anyone
while filming suggesting that helped him
keep his american accent on screen
sheehan blew us away with his wild
performance as klaus in umbrella academy
while this is the first time we noticed
him on the american screen
he's been performing for far longer most
notably as nathan young in the british
tv show
misfits you should see the looks on your
faces
classic his accent in misfits wasn't
british though it was his natural accent
irish originally from port leash ireland
the actor doesn't often do an american
accent which is a surprise considering
how convincing he is in umbrella academy
tom holland is probably best known for
his portrayal of spider-man and much
like his character he also has a bit of
a secret
did you know holland is actually english
born in surrey the actor began
performing at a young age and even made
his debut
on the west end in london the cast of
spider-man homecoming
got a taste of his natural british
accent while filming as he did slip into
it without noticing
some scenes even had to be re-cut to fix
the accent slips
holland credits his on-point accent to
obsessive practice and studying
people he knew who were american first
step is getting the accent right if you
don't get the accent right then you may
as well not
do it robbie has had stellar
performances in major hollywood hits
including the wolf of wall street
bombshell and birds of prey
considering the success she's had in
america it may come as a surprise to
know that she's actually from dalby
australia funnily enough
the actress had a dialect coach for an
australian soap opera
neighbors my australian accent was too
strong
even for neighbours pretty shocking
considering we wouldn't have known she
was australian based on her portrayals
in american films
liam hemsworth definitely made his mark
in hollywood with great films like the
last
song isn't it romantic and the hunger
games
the actor is even more talented and
hardworking than people may realize
since the american accent he's so often
done isn't natural
natalie you look beautiful hemsworth is
originally from melbourne australia
and has said that he works on his accent
often with a coach
and learned a lot watching american
television sir sharonin has
quickly been climbing the ranks in
america while the actress was born in
the bronx
she was born to irish parents and moved
to ireland when she was three to live in
county carlow
ronan has dazzled on screen with her
american accent in lady bird and little
women and brought her natural
irish accent to the film brooklyn the
actress learned the american accent
watching seinfeld on tv
and used to speak in accents with her
father for fun whenever my dad and i
would just be messing around we'd always
do accents that was kind of the
automatic thing for us to do
she has also given credit to the amazing
dialect coaches that have helped her
nail that american accent
the 13 reasons why star blew us away not
only by her performance
but her deceivingly american accent the
actress who played hannah baker in the
netflix series
is a kiwi did you know she's originally
from perth australia
langford said she learned the accent
from watching films
the actress also credits her skilled
accent work to her musicality and said
it's helped her nail the nuances
i'm a little bit musical so if if i
listen to something so like i had to do
a scottish accent
james mcavoy impressed us in films like
it chapter 2
x-men first class and especially in
split
a film where he played 23 different
parts varying in age
and gender not only was it an impressive
feat for any actor but mcavoy had the
added obstacle of
accent work since he is originally from
glasgow scotland
how scottish are you i guess is what i'm
asking uh i'm the phil i'm the real deal
i'm the full
square sausage he said in an interview
that different postures for different
characters helped him to get the voices
right and bring the personalities to
life
who knew the actress who impressed us
with her acting chops
in knives out hereditary and
unbelievable is originally from
blacktown
australia it's hard to believe since her
american accent is so strong
really do not like working with dialect
coaches because it makes me so
self-conscious about what i'm doing
we know him as billy from stranger
things and jason and power rangers
but what we aren't so familiar with is
his role in real life
an australian in america the perth born
actor says he works on the accent a lot
but even with all the practice his
accent did slip in season three of
stranger things
but you gotta say rip up so you almost
replace that er with a name
superman is an american hero while henry
cavill played the hero
he isn't actually american at all cavill
hails from jersey in the british isles
and admits that he had quite a bit of
trouble mastering his american dialect
the witcher actor says it's just
something you get used to
and need to exercise the muscles in your
mouth and throat
if i were to stay in an american accent
all day it ends up getting quite tiring
because it's not my natural accent
the boy who stole our hearts in the last
summer and the hate u give has been
living in riverdale for the past few
years
portraying the beloved redhead archie
when he's not busy trying to choose
between betty and veronica
it turns out you may find him in new
zealand his home country born and raised
in auckland
apple was on australian screens before
he rose to fame in america
according to the actor he didn't work on
his accent for riverdale with other
people it was just something he was able
to do
while his american accent is strong appa
has admitted that he struggles with
british accents
fun fact the actor has said the hardest
one for me is
saying girlfriend we wonder how betty
and veronica feel about that one
last but certainly not least we have the
beloved
peter dinklage dinklage is the only
actor on our list who is
actually from america the new jersey
born actor has had an incredible career
on screen but some of his most notable
roles have been in british productions
some of his career highlights were
definitely game of thrones and the
chronicles of narnia
though these major roles were performed
with a british accent
dinklage has plenty of credits with his
natural american accent as well
though most of the time his accent is on
point he did have a few accent clubs
while doing game of thrones
i don't want to hear it help me save
this city
not sure where that irish came from but
he's so good
we can look past it these actors were
not only amazing performers
but had the added work of accents and
certainly succeeded
were you surprised to find out any of
these actors actually have a different
accent than you thought
did you ever notice that many of the
stars in american productions are
actually from elsewhere which actor's
accent is the most
convincing let us know what you think in
the comments section don't forget to
click those like and subscribe buttons
to keep up with all our content
bye